just as long as it tastes like cheese
and I care about
hello hello hello we are back at it
again another fast-food restaurant has a
new menu item can you guess what it is
queso dip grab a Triple A which I'm
kinda but actually I feel like Chipotle
is case it should probably be good I'm
very excited to get it I'm gonna try it
I'm gonna bring it back to the office
anything you know my co-workers like it
let's do it I'm excited I'm a big chip
Oatley fan I would say I grew up with
kid Oba so a little biased people for
birthdays and Christmas give me Chipotle
gift cards I don't need to play that
much actually I'm a Chipotle advocate
activist philanthropist and I used to
work in Tripoli I love to pull it
I feel like Kazon ships is like the
go-to app at Mexican restaurants I'm
pretty excited to try it because I know
some other restaurants that have a
pretty good case so like Mo's and other
tex-mex places
I feel like cased it was more of you're
at home hanging with your friends and
like you have chips with salsa and also
cases I think as long as it's warm it's
good by me I don't care what it is I
just want to try it I just like cheese
it is orange that's not what I was
expecting
looks like we have yellow queso here not
white yeah I see like some little chili
fixings in there maybe it smells pretty
spicy that's some spice in the smell a
little bit of color some stays on in
there maybe to me it smells kind of like
enchilada sauce
I am scraping up all the chunks so I
will say that my review is chunk list
you should just do a little little mix
first break up that that oil fat layer
Wow I'm just gonna get like a big old
glob
I see there's a lot of flavor there's
some citrus there's some spice if you
get the medium salsa at Chipotle then
you can handle the spice of the queso
it's like the consistency of apple sauce
mmm that being said I am continuing to
eita in front of your face I feel like
this also gives me like classic nacho
vibes putting on burrito like this I'm
like in like mud my bowl my burrito boy
your entree is a way oh absolutely
if I were drunk and going to Chipotle
and just wanted some cheesy goodness I
would still get this it passes my my
queso bar Chipotle still rules oh yeah
bill oh finish the chips yeah fresh
baked chips okay so that's the scoop
Chipotle now has K so they finally gave
the people what they want overall people
really liked the queso some people
thought it was a little too spicy or
that it had a weird consistency but the
general consensus was that people would
want to include the K so in their meal a
Chipotle if you've been to New York and
you've tried the Chipotle queso or if
you'd like to try the new Chipotle queso
let us know in the comments below and
that's about it I'll just be sitting
here on this couch until the next fast
food restaurant releases something new
[Music]